oh it's good to finally talk to you you
too
are you in Stockholm or where are you
yeah I'm kind of in Stockholm I mean I
Sola okay it's close to Stockholm but
it's it's not Stockholm but it's very
yeah very close okay I just managed to
get back from I was in LA when kind of
yeah like I got back from LA a week
before the corona virus basically yeah
so I just managed to get back home sweet
Sweden's dealing with this thing way
different than the rest of the world is
how's that what is that like actually
it's I think you know there's a lot of
headlines and you know stuff being said
and written by it's really I would say
it's handled quite well here um I mean
because the thing is that if the Swedish
government tells the Swedish people that
you need to do that you know this and
this people are actually gonna do it so
it's it's I mean when the Swedish
government gives the recommendation it's
not like something people don't care
about like they really listen so it's
basically like you know having a law you
know for it so people actually listen so
I think yeah yeah people people trust
the government over there more than they
do here yes that's exactly what it is
yes for sure
and I'm actually Norwegian so I feel
like I can be like objective and like
see yeah it was working not but I
actually think Sweden is doing quite a
good job yeah yeah it's it's I've read a
few things about it and it seems like
some of the stuff they have or some of
the rules at least that they have in
place are really similar to what we have
here I'm in Florida Wow
and Florida I mean they have a lot of
strict like legal restrictions that you
supposed to follow but most people
aren't really following them and it
sounds almost like in a way Sweden's
rules are probably just as effective as
what's going on where I am right now
it's just people here just pushing it
way harder than they should be right
right and here it's not really necessary
to push it that hard because like right
mister says something everyone is like
okay yeah yes so yeah
you're right so you're in Florida yeah
yeah Florida yep I'm so jealous it's
very different from your part of the
world yes no today it's like so I'm just
great it's almost like purple like it's
so great I mean yeah I'm like I I need
some Sun so I've listened to a couple of
your a couple of your talks your TED
talk by the way I have to ask you how
the hell you were able to explain the
meaning of ass to mouth to an auditorium
full of professional people like that
that's like years of like experience
okay
I have to give credit to the years of
experience cuz I'm not really like I'm
not bothered by it you know right no but
it just it takes a lot o to me but yeah
but I mean obviously like you need some
poker face going on for sure but it's
like I don't really I don't really I
don't know I don't think like what's the
big deal like it's we got to talk about
it
you know yeah yeah yeah you said that
you have you've interviewed a lot of
porn performers and people in the
industry basically the thought that I
was trying to get across was that a lot
of famous porn stars or widely no
important performers come from really
challenging backgrounds and really rough
childhoods like stripping or being a
porn star can bring in a lot of money
and it seems like a really appetizing
thing and a really obvious solution to
get out of those terrible situations as
a child because you can make a lot of
money doing those things right yeah have
you noticed anything like that have you
noticed thing similar backgrounds to
people you've talked to yeah for sure
I kind of like before I went in and did
started doing interviews with people in
porn I was kind of I was kind of like
thinking back to the people I met and in
classic prostitution and still like even
though like I've worked with this you
for years I was still actually expecting
a higher standard when it came to the
people important like in terms of their
living conditions and in terms of the
money they were making and just like
yeah I was just expecting more glam I
guess more glam more money more
Hollywood more you know red carpets but
it's I would say obviously there are
people making a lot of money in porn for
sure but the majority they won't even
last for a year you know like so it
would be like a quick in-and-out and the
money won't be that much really to the
majority and when it comes to the
challenging backgrounds I would say yeah
I do agree to some extent that it is
unfortunately that's like because even I
was like oh I I want to be wrong you
know I don't want to have this this like
this is what I think I'm gonna meet you
know and then everything is just gonna
take my boxes so I was like prove me
wrong but yes Lee I have heard you know
some horror stories when it comes to
people important and why they entered
their childhood growing up in poverty
growing up in perhaps homelessness being
you know victims of abuse physical
sexual you know foster care like all of
these factors are yeah they are
irrelevant and yeah for sure and I would
also say like one of the perhaps like
key factors when it comes to entering
porn or prostitution or you know
whatever is the sexual abuse like the
trauma the undealt with trauma so that
is a key factor to to joining porn I
think and the trauma sorry I just do
here my dog in the background yeah I
hear my thing it's hilarious what kind
of dog is it no we'll leave it in you
should get you should put him in the
chair right behind you we could see him
talk I was like dude buddy please just
be quiet yeah but no it seems like porn
performers are treated like at least by
the agents or the producers in the
industry as just like sex objects with
an expiration date and the expiration
date is very really soon right right I
mean yes that's I'm her producers say
that actually talking about it as as to
like bringing in fresh meat you know
they want to offer something new to the
consumer and once the consumer is kind
of fed up with that then you know she or
he is gone and then you know off to the
next one so yes it is it seems to be you
know quite a you know quick in-and-out
for for most people yeah
is there is that industry big in Sweden
or was that mainly in LA where you were
doing all that research in LA and yeah
LA in Vegas okay but it exists in Sweden
for sure but not to that extent at all I
think like we have more more pour in
production here than people are aware of
but still compared to what you guys have
in the u.s. like it's nothing yeah la is
such a crazy place yeah it is I think we
all could agree on that um but there's
just something like it's so I don't know
if it's like cheesy but I absolutely
love LA like it's just so you really I
adore it yes I do
and my favorite part actually is
downtown and everyone keeps telling me
like oh you can't be there it's
dangerous and I'm like but it's where
the I think most of authentic people are
you know because it's so much
homelessness and so many people with you
know difficulties but you like sit down
and have a conversation with one of them
it's like to me that's like the most
rewarding yeah my best memories from
relay are from like conversations
downtown really yes for sure yes I
witness the amount of homeless people
there is sir it's absurd it's like
nothing else it's like nowhere else
nowhere else yeah you're right and to me
I get so like I know it's a bit perhaps
I don't know naive you could call it but
to me I'm like how is this not fixable
you know it's not like it's a million
people in homelessness like it's still
an amount of people that you know it
should be possible to handle this
to to offer housing and provide support
[Laughter]